Before we jump into spreadsheets okay
the idea is that we've sort of been
treating decision support systems kind
of like a are a monolithic blob do you
know monolithic means monitor wanna
think it means it's just one kind of
they're all the same you know and you
sort of don't really have any
distinctions or understanding of how
there's diversity in within a group okay
but the fact is decision support systems
it's a very very broad category okay and
there are four main types of decision
support system that I'm gonna try to
explain I'm gonna go through them in
order of complexity now because this is
the end of the term we're just going to
get through one but I want to talk about
the four up okay so this is types of
decisions of what system and going from
simplest to most sophisticated okay
we're gonna start with spreadsheets very
very merciful
we're gonna move up two relational
databases and I'm specifying relational
why do you think that is why do I say
relation I'm not just yeah that's right
I mean if I would if I want a flat file
I'd be up here spreadsheet it's just a
flat ball out of it
okay it's two-dimensional yeah alter
relational databases yeah an interesting
thing called an expert system which is
far more related to people as you see
and excuse me the last most
sophisticated type is the artificial
neural
raggedy it's not just more not just more
complicated but more you know you need
to have more complex jargon to go with
it to make it appropriately you know
so as as you're often seen right you've
got four different categories and then
go up in in complexity and cost in the
time it takes to develop them okay but
just because something is more
sophisticated and takes more time to
make does it mean it's better okay I
hope you're getting this is a theme
through the course right then sometimes
you'll want to pick a simpler one
because just it'll just do the job
better even if it's just very
straightforward so these are the four
types at warm-up we'll get onto these
guys next term but let's dive into
spreadsheets okay so the first thing I
want to ask you is the question I want
to the process or have in your mind is
analysis analyzing can we remember I
know it's a long time ago in your year
nines analyze he was one of the early
processes that's the definition so the
idea is you start off with raw material
you just got tons of data but you don't
have any sense out of it you're not sure
what it means you're not sure what's
significant I'm you're not sure what's
important okay it's no no categories or
it's not organized in any way okay so
analyzing right it's about making things
meaningful meaningful right now can you
see why in many ways this is the key
process to keep in your head when it
comes to making decisions why why
analysis is so important
okay good thank you right so the whole
idea in fact if you remember if you
think back to when we did analyzing like
a whole year ago often the endpoint of
analyzing was actually to make a choice
right the reason why I'm sort of um
spending trial time trying to understand
this information since the patterns and
trends is so that I can say well
therefore I notice it's always really
hot around December January that's an
interesting pattern or trend is
meaningful okay yes how mysterious right
but what I'll do is I'll make decisions
according to that analysis okay and
obviously event so it's a trivial
example okay so